today on campaign check we're looking at
the Liberal Democrat manifesto they've
set out a range of policies from
tackling climate change recruiting more
teachers and a big infrastructure
investment plan so question one are the
promises as generous as they sound they
claim that once they cancel brexit the
boost economic growth will give the
government an extra 50 billion pounds in
revenue but question to do their sums
really add up let's take a look and here
are their plans you can see here the top
bar here shows you how much they want to
raise in revenues on the bottom how much
they plan to spend and you can see
there's more revenues than there is
spending the top bar is longer than the
bottom bar that means they get a current
surplus but where are they actually
planning on spending their money well
the bulk is gonna go on education and
childcare actually 20,000 teachers
smaller class sizes and a new universal
free childcare scheme which will cost a
whopping 14 billion pounds nearly half
of that entire chunk there's more than
six billion dollar anti-poverty measures
you got a seven point seven billion on
the NHS and a host of other measures
sounds like a lot doesn't it but here's
the thing it might not be quite as
generous as it looks and to see why look
at the top bar next to that remain bonus
we'll get to that in a second the green
bit is the Tories spending round from
earlier this year you remember more NHS
spending more police officers and so on
well instead of putting all of their
spending on top of that the Lib Dems are
effectively canceling that spending
round and starting all over again it's a
little bit odd so in some areas like
education they seem to go further than
the Tories but in some areas they may
actually be spending less and actually
the majority of the revenues this bar on
the far right hand side of that top bar
you can see that's new tax increases so
penny on income tax CGT measures even a
new duty on legalized cannabis but back
to that remain bonus over there does
that really stack up well it all comes
back to this chart most economists think
the economy will grow more if the UK
stays inside the EU see the difference
between those top two lines there and a
stronger economy means more tax revenue
which means well a remain bonus or
whatever you want to call it but because
that's an economic forecast there's a
big risk that number isn't right
but actually that bonus is only a
relatively small fraction of their
fiscal plans and it's not even the most
surprising thing in their manifesto
which is actually rather more austere
than it looks and in some areas they may
end up being even more austere than the
Tories